hi there this is steve kaufman here um
hopefully this is going to work i've had
some trouble with my uh with the audio
on imovie and i even took my computer
into the store and uh
basically what you have to do with a
computer when it isn't working properly
is to turn it off and turn it back on
again so i think that's what the problem
was for some reason
i've had a number of requests a number
of questions and i'm always glad to have
questions and then like it shows that
there's people out there listening which
is good
and the questions i've had
seem to
deal with this issue of
how long does it take to become fluent
how does one get from
passive learning being able to read and
and and understand when we're listening
how do you get to where you can speak
well
uh
and what are the obstacles
and i might just go a little bit into
this whole issue of of learning words
versus learning grammar because there
are also some comments
about um
uh you know what the major obstacles or
what's most difficult in a language now
i'm going to ramble a little bit because
i don't like to write these things out
ahead of time and and so forth but i
will make reference to an article that i
wrote some time ago
which is in three parts it's called
seven i believe seven misconceptions
about language learning and it has a
part a and a part b and a part c
and the part c refers to the three
stages of language learning and at that
time i said there were three stages
there was an initial stage which i said
would take 60 to 90 hours and i'm
assuming that the average person has an
hour a day on average to spend some days
they don't do anything and some days on
the weekend they get keen and they do
more
at length we recommend recommend an hour
a day
mostly listening
so 60 to 90 hours is the first stage
that's where
you learn some words
all of a sudden a language that was very
strange that was just a bunch of noise
it starts to have meaning it's very
exhilarating it's very exciting
uh to all of a sudden be able to make
sense out of something that made no
sense whatsoever
a lot of people in that initial stage
they're too concerned about nailing
things down
trying to remember grammar rules
remember every word
you're not going to the grammar rules
are not going to make much sense until
you have a lot more exposure to the
language the words all seem the same
and so all you can do is hope that you
you start to all of a sudden see start
it's like a great big fog or it's like a
jigsaw puzzle and you're starting to get
a bit of a sense of what it's going to
look like and that's say two to three
months a lot of listening
if you're on the link system you're
saving words and phrases you're
reviewing them so that's the first stage
the second stage uh which is where we
start and i should say in the first
stage you really only have
you're stuck with beginner content now i
think it may be possible to start with
authentic content some of the podcasts
we have at link which are genuine
conversations often
conversations use
you know
high frequency vocabulary it's possible
that people can start from scratch as
long as the audio and the text are both
there and they have a system like link
but in the second phase therefore after
say two months or 60 hours
it might be longer if you're dealing
with a different writing system as in
chinese
but now you're in the second phase and
here you want to be dealing with
authentic content
so here again that's why i link we fill
our library with authentic content
choose something of interest listen
read
learn the words focus on the words say
phrases because the phrases embody the
grammar you can start looking at some
grammar rules i mean you can always look
at the grammar explanations even as a
beginner get yourself a bit of an
overview just don't worry about learning
them just don't worry about trying to
produce them correctly
so in the second phase then you're
listening to a lot of authentic content
you're
you know if in the first phase you
didn't speak a lot in the second phase
you start to speak a little bit more
i think in my in my text i indicated
what sort of vocabulary level that would
be
i think i said in the first stage there
that you would only know about a
thousand words after two months or so
knowing doesn't mean you aren't going to
forget them by the way
the second stage would take you
to i didn't put a number here
but uh
yeah it's gotta be about three or four
thousand words
and there we're looking at 180 to 360
hours which is like uh
six months to a year so that's a long
period there you're but you are dealing
with authentic content and there i
recommend conversations because they're
easier than articles or literature
because articles or literature tend to
use more difficult vocabulary and one of
the themes one of my main beliefs is
that words vocabulary these things are
much more important than grammar that's
what's holding you back you're missing
the words
and so here you're going to spend six
months to a year increasing your
vocabulary during that period you may
speak you may not speak depends on where
you are if you have the opportunity to
speak go for it if you don't
fine
uh
now
then so typically say after a year
roughly you're now approaching the third
stage now this is the stage where you're
gonna go for fluency
now here you continue very much the same
kinds of activities do what's easy to do
listen and read work on your words
that's easy to do you can do it anytime
i can listen i can listen when i when i
walk when i drive when i wash the dishes
it's easy to do i can read i enjoy it
here you're going to move to more
difficult content perhaps literature
always being guided mostly by what
interests you okay and hopefully now
you're accumulating accumulating more
and more words the grammar is starting
to look a little bit you know make more
sense to you now that you read the
grammar explanations you understand what
they're talking about
um
you know i'm in link so what i do now is
i tag words and phrases by gender you
know masculine dative so forth from my
russian so there are little tricks there
are other systems out there that can
help you
um so now how do you get to speaking
well and people say well i can read but
i can't speak first of all let me say
that i have yet to come across a person
who can read well and who understands
well and can't speak
i have had people tell me that they read
well and i say do you read novels in
english for example people say i'm you
know in english i don't speak well but
but i can read well well i say do you
like reading a novel in english is it
comfortable for you to sit down and read
a novel and they say well no not really
it's a lot of work well then you don't
yet read well
you should be able to pick up whatever
language it is and pick up a novel pick
up a magazine but more than a magazine a
novel and enjoy reading it to 300 pages
that that means that you read well if
you have that degree of comfort in
reading
i believe you'll be able to speak in
most cases and similarly you have to
understand what you hear and i have
worked in environments where i spoke the
language and the other person you know i
spoke the
local language whether it be japanese
french and i was dealing with locals
therefore who wanted to speak english
and i can tell when they don't
understand and it's very often the case
and it's very very
unsettling so you have to be able to
understand very well so that the person
who's speaking to you in the language
doesn't get that blank stare when you
didn't quite understand so if you have
those two things going for you and those
things can be developed through a lot of
listening and reading then you're on
your way now to speak well you have to
speak
you know to speak well comes a point
where you have to gather all the
tools that you've accumulated all the
words and the phrases and the practice
and the familiarity with the language
and you have to put it to the test
uh
and and that takes a while
it takes a while and if you are not in a
situation where you have have the you
know a frequent opportunity to use the
language
you know that ability to speak will be
potential dormant
but you won't be able to fully develop
it and speaking has a lot of advantages
even in an early stage when you aren't
speaking very much i believe it it
activates the mirror neurons i won't go
into that i think it makes you aware of
where your gaps are it makes you more
observant more attentive i always say
the brain will learn naturally but the
brain misses things and so to make the
brain more attentive make the brain pay
attention
speaking making mistakes writing making
mistakes that all helps
and it and so you do some of it at the
different stages you end up doing more
and more of it as you progress and of
course it depends on on the opportunity
you have but ultimately
you have to speak a lot
and one other thing too is that people
worry about their pronunciation don't
worry about your pronunciation worry
about your phrasing have natural
phrasing and that's going to make
your interlocutor the person you're
speaking to in that language make them
feel comfortable i know people who have
an accent but are totally into using the
right phrases they sound natural they
express themselves
express themselves very well they don't
stumble like i just did
and that's good now if you
pronunciation is about vanity so if you
are really concerned about your
pronunciation then you have to
find someone whose voice and intonation
you like in an audiobook or whatever and
listen to them over and over and over
and over again to sort of ingrain that
pronunciation in you i'm not talking
about people who can't make the basic
sounds and i'm running out of time i'll
continue again some other time